you
hi everyone it's Jerry here's another
cool endgame study that I'd like to
share with you this one composed by
Joseph munch it is white to move and
it's up to you to try and find the best
continuation as usual I encourage you to
spend some time with these maybe set
this position up on one of your own
boards and work it out these are
excellent calculation exercises so again
it is White's move it's up to you to
find the best continuation okay before I
show the solution let me point out a
feature or two with this composition the
first one of the first things to
recognize is that this section here is
completely immobile either white or
black can move and this plays a great
role because if black is without there B
and C pond or there B and C pond can no
longer make any legal moves then we will
have reached a stalemate position so as
it turns out in this composition here
it's very time sensitive so we need to
be extra delicate with our moves in the
tempos that we we invest one of the one
of the ideas here is to try and get your
knight to the f7 square if our night is
on f7 that'll be checkmate now how you
go about doing that is the tricky part
one of the approaches is to start off
with the move Knight to d4 and this is
not the only path I'll just highlight
one but basically Knight d4 f3 g5 and
then finally f7 trying to get the knight
to the f7 square is the is the trick
here but it takes four moves to do that
do we have four moves to get our Knight
to f7 suppose we begin with Knight d4
black plays b4 it's the only legal move
Knight f3 b3 Knight g5 we are almost
there to deliver mate however black is
able to play b2 that's
check we take one of the two and now
promote to a queen with check and if we
take the queen where one moves short
this position is stalemate we don't get
to play Knight to f7 doing something
other than taking the Queen well we've
run the risk of losing in fact we are
losing after Queen takes G so how do we
manage to get our Knight to this f7
square it's going to take us four moves
what path do we choose well the very
first move is not a knight move and it's
not a king move either
it's a pawn move let me point out first
that if we try a King move like King
takes pawn there would be be for our
Knight moves b3 check King somewhere b2
it's not going to work out we're
actually much slower with an attempt
like this one one trick maybe in your
calculation to try King b2 thinking well
if black promotes now we take here
b4 Knight d3 b3 we get out of the pawns
way so there's legal moves and black is
not in stalemate B 295 b1 equals let's
say a knight as otherwise Knight f7 will
be mate so that's a check King here and
next we'll be able to mate the problem
with this is that black does not have to
push c1 but can instead play b4 and this
is not going to allow the night to get
to f7 successfully or in time I should
say after Knight d4 there is now c1
equals Queen or suppose even the knight
place here there would be b3 night d3
black promotes black pushes with check
and again there's just not going to be
any time to get our Knight to f7 in fact
we are a long way off from our desired
f7 post so the winning continuation and
the only move that wins is
d4 and it's extremely important that the
pawn go to squares as we will soon see
we cannot we need to make use of the d3
square soon enough so this is the first
move in fact this puzzle position turns
out to be a matin 7 the first move is d4
b4 is the only reply and now King to d2
and this is what I like about this
puzzle the first move d4 is now clearing
away for a new legal move King to D to B
for King to d2 and this is yet another
instance of white moving and allowing a
new legal move by another piece night 2
c1 is now available and notice with the
king's post on D - it is sidestepping
this be pawns advance with check this is
the only move to promote to something it
doesn't matter what it is we now take b3
we now go to d3 notice our pawn head
moved two squares we need to make use of
that d3 Square with our Knight B 295 the
only way to prevent made on f7 next is
by promoting to a night with check we
simply move up and pick your favorite
square does not matter now we are
finally able to get to that f7 square
form 8 this is a very clever puzzle I
really like this idea the thought that
goes into this composition of moving one
piece and then sneaking your King right
up like so in the place where that pond
was and then having a similar idea where
once the King moves there's a new square
available for another piece and only
with this exact variation will be in
fact to be able to go ahead and deliver
me and as mentioned this one turns out
to be a mate in 7 so anyhow feel free to
leave any feedback in this video in the
comment section below I thought it was a
cool one and I hope you enjoyed it
that's all for now take care bye
you